le 13 le jaune 13 est ce qu'il ya un
jaune 13 oui par alain bourgeois merci
d'être là merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes alors je vérifie vous êtes dans le
très chaude c'est magnifique parce que
vous faire un bisou
merci venez comment ça va quand vous
appelez tania tania alors tania on va
jouer avec toute l'équipe vous les aimez
bien je les regardais tous les soirs ça
va qui vous a envie de faire un petit
bisou
elle aime bien m'attire mais ça devrait
aller c'est plus du bisou battue
[Applaudissements]
jusque là tout allait bien et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ensuite des réseaux
sociaux se sont déchaînés contre vous
pour quel motif pas parce que j'avais un
voile du coup quand je suis rentré chez
moi sur twitter j'ai reçu plein d'
insulte juste parce que j'étais voile et
du coup moi je comprenais pas parce que
je comprends pas moi ce que j'avais fait
de mal pour moi y'a rien de mal on vous
reprocher simplement d'être voilées rien
d'autre c'est ça ça prenait quelle forme
se sait mais ces insultes j'ai réussi
plusieurs insultes et en fait moi je
comprends je prends parce que ce qu'il y
avait du mal parce que on a juste on a
juste joué et enfin si j'étais voilées
ou non ça change rien ça ne changeait
rien alors ça nous a tous attristés
consterné à commencer par le premier
intéressé cyril hanouna oui la séquence
qui m'a fait le plus de peine de toute
l'histoire de mon émission c'est qu'un
jour j'ai fait un jeu concours et je
tire au sort quelqu'un dans le public et
il se trouve que la personne qui étaient
tirés au sort et qui a gagné le cadeau
c'était une jeune femme voilée est venu
sur le plateau elle s'est faite et
esquinté sur les réseaux sociaux ça va
c'est ça ma fait qu'elles montrent pas
une tourelle qui étaient là qui veut et
est derrière elle a été traumatisée
c'est une des séquences les plus tristes
de l'émission est-ce que vous avez été
longuement traumatisée après les
attaques dont vous avez été victime on
sait ce qu'il ya des gens qui voient là
autour de ce plateau on reçoit des
insultes quotidiennement mais on est un
peu blindé il faut le dire mais quand on
est un débutant dans l'insultent sur
twitter ou sur les autres réseaux je
sais que ça fait un effet assez violents
vis du mal parce que je comprenais pas
et
et comment vous avez réagi aux mesures
énoncées commun tania vu une très jolie
présente un système très jolis prénoms
merde alors
est-ce que vous avez porté plainte
contre certaines des personnes qui vous
insulter ou qui veut maintenant
je suis passé à autre chose moi parce
que c'était c'était que virtuel c'est
surtout le risque de recommencer demain
matin oui donc vous n'avez pas passer à
autre chose dans la semaine qui vient
malheureusement non c'est ça j'arrête
pas dû lire tu les lis pas oui ah ouais
tu fais comme nous isabelle ce
témoignage je sais que moi ça me touche
beaucoup mais toute l'émission touche
beaucoup en fait pour tout vous dire
c'est pour ça que je voulais que cédric
face ce livre parce que ce soit vous la
famille shaw via dans votre dignité que
ce soit voulait gilet jaune dans vos
combats que ce soit chacun d'entre vous
finalement qui est engagé en politique
que ce soit vouera quel que soit soit
vous laurence que ce soit vous jean
chacun vous êtes des polarités du monde
politique et des polarités très
différentes vous êtes tous là ce soir
autour de la table donc vous engueuler
de temps en temps moi je moi j'étais un
peu en dehors à vous regardez où vous
engueuler de temps en temps mais vous
discutez vous échangez il se passe
quelque chose tania elle est là elle est
là il m'a il ya quelque chose qui me
touche énormément quand cyril parle de
vous et quand il parle de toutes les
femmes qu'il reçoit sur ce plateau est
dit on essentialise pas une femme vous
n'êtes pas une femme voilée vous êtes
une femme qui porte le voile et vous
êtes une femme qui porte le voile parce
que vous avez envie de le porter et je
trouve que toute cette france qui est là
autour de la table ce soir elle est
magnifique elle est multiple elle est
diverse et je suis en fait très fier
effectivement d'avoir publié ce livre
pour ça et si pour ce faire il faut
endosser fièrement les critiques de
toute une partie des éditorialistes chez
qu'écouter ben c'est tout mon honneur
que de l'avoir fait
on sait que le voile c'est une question
voilà qui fait beaucoup couler d'encre
hauts-de-seine il ya des débats
passionnés est ce que vous vous portez
le voile tout simplement ou est-ce que
vous êtes une militante vous militez
pour le port du voile dans l'espace
public non moi je porte le voile est
simplement moi je fais ma vie de mon
côté
il n'ya pas de démarche politique dans
un appel je trouve est ce que je peux
demander aux producteurs quand même
d'exprimer leur avis là pour ou contre
le voile dans l'espace public et gagnent
veulent intervenir oui moi je suis
favorable au voile pour une raison très
simple je suis laïc à 100% par oui la
laïcité consiste à mêler ci consiste à
ne pas considérer qu'un psy religieux
est un signe religieux c'est pour pour
la laïcité du point de vue de la laïcité
vous porter une casquette là où porter
un béret vous portez un chapeau mais le
l'état la sphère étatique n'a pas à dire
que j'aime porter non la laïcité c'est
de dire à reconnaître un signe religieux
dans le vêtement mais en revanche je
mets un bémol c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
voit dans dans la sphère publique je
crois qu'il ya un échange de visage
entre les citoyens je vous donne mon
visage vous me le donner la burqa les
femmes qui cachent leur visage me pose
un énorme problème parce que ce n'est
plus du jeu elle retire les champs non
elle retire les champs castrais guen
sait très bien faire vivre et non parce
que les gens confondent il ya beaucoup
même de téléspectateurs qui disent que
le voile ça couvre non le voile il ya
des bonnes soeurs qui se promène dans la
rue lorsque les bonnes soeurs se promène
dans la rue les jeux est ce que tu
renvoies l'état nom est assombri dans le
riad émergent mon raisonnement quand
elles sont dans un lieu public elle
cesse immédiatement
du point de vue de l'état d'être des
religieuses elles ne sont religieuses en
tant que costumes que lorsqu'elles sont
dans leurs cercles et pour l'état si tu
veux un lagon un habit religieux que ce
soit une kippa que ce soit une croix
christique que ce soit un voile n'ont
aucune signification religieuse dans la
sphère publique aucune c'est ça la
définition de la laïcité et ceux qui
l'ont rejeté le texte c'est même assez
pervers parce qu'ils se sont arrangés
pour que parce qu'ils voulaient
combattre à l'époque les religieux
catholiques pour combattre le
catholicisme et ils ont trouvé ce truc
redoutable qui est que de dire non pour
nous ça ne veut rien dire cette croix
c'est une croix mais sait on voit pas à
quoi ces corps et les srt redoutable
parce que le piège dans le pays voulait
éviter c'était justement que les signes
fasse sens donc tout est égal à tous en
termes vestimentaire dans la sphère
laïque en revanche quand le visage n'est
plus proposé à autrui ça devient
extrêmement triste mais enfin un pays ne
s'en est jamais si un pays ne serait due
uniquement eloi c'était l'ère
effectivement la loi de 1905 j'entends
ce que tu dit yann mais le lin très
brillant a voulu simple le fait de
respecter la loi d'un pays ne suffit pas
sinon si je respecte le la noix du
brésil je suis brésilien il y a quelque
chose dans chaque pays qui s'appelle
l'identité nationale qui va au delà de
la loi dans le sind et donc notamment en
bronze en france il ya quelque chose on
nous appelle la discrétion religieuse on
se balade pas en portant en bandoulière
sa province ont lieu ces quelques c'est
une un principe qui a été respectée tune
a depuis pris ce que tu es là les
santons géants réduisons les cités c'est
pas d'accord les galanais aujourd'hui
encore aujourd'hui moi je vais rien
contrairement à toi sa nouvelle fois le
voile n'est pas un bout de tissu le
genre elle est taboue de sharjah
d'offrir les gens
et
quitter le rassemblement national et à
la lettre le syded est neutralisée dès
que tu sors il ya un public le signe
religieux et neutralisés il y dix sous
marin habité chez nous de la voix ne
fait pas partie de la tradition
française ne fait pas partie de
l'identité française moi je le vois les
gens en forme à la laïcité je conçois
que les pages de la fin des débats ne
vois tu ne sois pas les anciens malades
de les en france mais il leur appartient
à ce moment là d'aller vivre leur
religion c'est
grâce à mal et est retournée jaber
tradition république à l'évidence ou
laïque elle n'a pas prévu ça excusez moi
c'est laissez nous vivre offrant tahiti
on s'avoue plaît je me
pardonnez moi mais vous êtes à côté de
cette jeune femme tout en dignité qui
est magnifique là à côté de vous et que
vous les noms mais pardonnez moi on
s'est dit regardant dans les yeux quel
effet partie vivante aux françaises
alors donnez moi cette jeune femme pour
vous ne fait pas partie de l'identité
française c'est la france est la france
2 depuis la fin de la mission mais
coûterait bande le fener partie des
provinces
la loi de 1905 outre-manche à danton
dirigeront sac a été adopté alors que la
république a maté le catholicisme a eu
des milliers d'anti jeu sur une des
républiques milliers d'églises et de
monastères et ses paires mais j'en ai si
un accord avec l'islam radical et
ensuite on verra ce que tu mérites
jamais chers accoutrement c'est un mot
il admis cet humiliant que c'est
inadmissible prononcer mais je ratisse
tout les genres abc s'est péjoré
cadastraux mafieuses